when did you guys watch star wars the
original trilogy for your first time
first time in college senior year i
watched
in college yeah i mean yeah like you
watched star wars in college
in the 21st century did you know that
darth vader
spoiler alert i did i was and my buddy
at that point it was like cultural
yeah it was bad my buddy was a meme at
that appalling spoiler alert
during um episode one about the emperor
yeah it wasn't good yeah that's not good
oh he didn't know the emperor was
no i didn't know i was watching for the
first time
i was like who's senator palpatine yeah
oh he's the emperor are you like
what all of my buddies like what so what
is your favorite star wars film
number one film of the nine it's
actually included
you can lose solo and rogue gotta be
three gotta be three underestimate my
power
you like revenge of the sith it's
actually dark i like it too i like it
i liked the one where i know people
didn't like it but with
the uh where they're doing the racing in
like
the thing is i watched four five six and
then one two three and the way that
three ended and fed into four did you
see rogue one
the one that goes and bridges the two i
did yeah rogue one is amazing well the
vader scene at the end
the rate of shane is incredible spoiler
alert